[Music]
keith is in carbondale illinois hi keith
what's up
hey dave and ken how are you guys doing
today better than we deserve what's up
so
we've been doing airplane for quite a
while but unfortunately before we
started that my wife attended a private
college back in 2006
where she took out about a 60 000
private student loan that her father
co-signed on which we obviously know now
that that was a horrible idea
um in 2008 her parents filed for
bankruptcy and then that sent her a loan
into default and ever since then there's
been no payments that have been made
towards that student loan it's been kind
of floating around ever since
um a couple weeks ago
she got a letter from a credit company
and they now said that her loan is uh 80
000 but they would be willing to settle
it for 20 thousand dollars do it um
so we're not sure if it's you know how
to make sure it's legit
or if we need to like go talk to an
attorney or someone to make sure that
that's all you know
a true statement or from a you know
reputable com company or they have the
account numbers and everything accurate
um we did ask for proof at one point and
they sent like photocopies of what the
loan looked like um and it was accurate
with
uh when she originally took it out um
but they they kind of talked to us you
know in prior years but more recently
you know a couple weeks ago they offered
to settle it um
but in in the document or in the letter
the one page letter it doesn't say that
it would necessarily settle it in full
but it does say a settlement amount yeah
well that's what they did that's what
they meant but just say i need further
clarification that if you accept twenty
thousand dollars cash as settlement in
full of this debt that no nothing
further will be owed i'll accept that
i'll accept that in an email
okay and just get that in rain that they
would sell that in full and not be able
to come back for you know anymore later
down the road exactly and the more
formal looking that document the better
but um i'm not going to sweat it too
much it's uh it's a fairly standard
practice in that world so it's not that
doesn't smell like a scam to me at all
it sounds like a normal thing
as a matter of fact i might i might
counter
offer well that's why i was wondering
should we ask if they would go lower
because they offered 20. originally it
was 60 now they say it's 80. yeah and
we're offering 75 percent off of the
balance so i wasn't sure if we should
offer a lesson just say you know if you
can come down a little more i think
we'll do it and just see what they say
okay
and see how far and if they say no way
then do it but if they say okay well
we'll do 15. then that one sentence made
you five grand
right right okay and uh now the only the
only caveat is that they did say ask to
be paid by the end of the month and if
they don't receive the payment by the
end of september that they could
challenge the terms which was a little
bit yeah well that would be normal the
offer is not you know standing forever
so have you got um
uh
have you i mean have you got a way to
get the money together i don't care if
you borrow it because you're already 60
80 000 in debt and we change that out
for 15 or 20. that's a good deal so even
if you put it on a credit card i'm okay
with that okay
yeah we've been doing the steps so we
actually paid everything else off
besides the student loans so we actually
have been kind of moving through the
steps to get to the point where you know
if they do reach out again we'll be
ready to you know oh god how much do you
have so we have a 20 000 emergency
fundraiser oh good good we'll call them
and settle the deal man
write them a check
no electronic access to your checking
account must be in writing
that's the two rules on settling a debt
you're going to be taxed on the
difference there'll be a 1099-c coming
where your debt forgiveness is taxable
event and that includes private student
loans